than you yeah ernie we're so you know
we're so lucky and blessed to have you
the leader of our team godfather
uh you're very kind and i just want to
thank every single person who works here
man
i did a hologram uh i mean we have some
amazing
amazing people who work here i just want
to thank everybody personally
everybody who's here everybody who's not
here
i know because of covet we kind of got
uh not everybody who's normally out here
is
is in the building but yeah shout out
shout out jason aunt
mickey normally there mickey oh the oh
oh
i want to shout out all the producers
yeah the old lady oh my god
what are you talking about oh my god
that make up mickey up tell us
okay i found my old makeup mickey oh
makeup mickey's not old
uganda producer uh keith and jared
jeremy levine jeremy levith and tim kyle
tim kyle
what's his name rob audio rob in the
film
where's your boy matt at kentucky
brother shaw what's his name
yeah thank you thank you man i
appreciate it brian
thank you draymond and let me shout out
to the other guys who were in my
category and
uh i mean scott van pelt was in there
mike tarico
uh is in there um
rachel nichols shut out rachel we love
you rachel rich eisen
uh can you say i mean
could you take this moment to you know
say something about receiving this award
because you didn't get
you're not it's not like you were on
stage so can we give you two minutes to
just
i don't do what you want i don't know
seriously i don't need two minutes
but i do but i do say you know what i
said on the
you know on the telecast tonight was
you know it's a get to job that we have
here
you know we get to do what we love um
i get to work with you guys i get to
work with that baseball crew you know
pedro martinez and curtis granderson and
jimmy rollins and
then there there are nights like this
where you get to receive something
in the company of those guys this could
have gone to any anybody in there
and but now you guys and then and then
you get to
you get to say hey we're very proud of
every
very proud of everybody in here and and
to share land my lovely wife of nearly
39 years thanks for putting up with mice
and larnie this is for you i have one
more trick
comes out that's for you right
that's even more impressive than uh no
on what you gave chuck
dude come on man you like that one i
love though that was going to be in the
ball room i tell you i know that's going
to be in check
i don't know where that rose came from
though
that's quite one